hey everybody John Luke here showing you
brand new gameplay of near automata we
got to capture this is about an hour and
a half into the game so don't worry
there are no story spoilers we're just
showing off some side quests and combat
I'm actually really excited about this
game I think it's quite charming and I'm
curious what you guys think about it and
if you want to see more near coverage
subscribe to GameSpot all right let's
get to the action
alert access point communications chen
according to our intel none of the
machines in this area are hostile we've
been seeing more and more enemies like
this lately they just stand there and
stare into space it's pretty weird
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the resistance camp huh we
should probably go talk to their leader
first thing
you're number two hmm you know about to
be um yes well the bunker told me to
expect you
my name is anemone I'm the leader of the
Android resistance that controls most of
this territory you must be the new
Scouts we heard about well I'm sure my
people will have plenty of information
for you please feel free to ask them
anything you like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
target location data obtained marking on
map
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's everything the supply trader
asked for man these chores are a real
pain in the butt huh the resistance is a
valuable ally to your huh
by helping them we also help ourselves
so no I don't think they're a pain yeah
yeah
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you
this is the place that weapons trader
was talking about uh-oh
I'm picking up hostile machine
life-forms
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that should be enough let's get these
back to the trader
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
report mail notification received from
access point
[Music]
you